jetzt kommen wir zu einer weiteren
weichte die mich wirklich schockiert hat
ich weiblich 18 beichte das mal extra zu
viele fehlstunden gegeben wurden damit
ich das schuljahr nicht schaffe das
verwechseln hey was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bayern nein ich habe hier
gläubiger schild drin aber ich gleich
raus leute was geht ab herzlich
willkommen beim neuen video ich hoffe
natürlich euch jetzt gut ja leute heute
steht was cooles an ich bin irgendwie
letzte woche spontan auf die idee
gekommen dass ich das eventuell man
machen könnte
ihr habt ja sehr wahrscheinlich am titel
schon gelesen es geht heute nämlich um
eure zeugnis beichten
ich meine wer kennt es nicht man kriegt
sein zeugnis und denkt sich so bei der
einen oder anderen sache okay das möchte
ich jetzt ungern so meinen eltern zeigen
habe ich auch schon photoshop
rübergezogen das gute war
ich war schon so mit zwölf jahren sehr
gut und photoshop und damit 13 nein also
mein eigenes zeug das habe ich wirklich
nie gefällt
ich habe allerdings zweimal das zeugnis
für freunde gefälscht und das konnte ich
wirklich gut also da hat man nichts
gesehen egal willkommen zum thema genau
vor einem jahr hat diese serie nenne ich
jetzt mal von mir gestartet ich reagiere
auf ihre zeugnisse und genau vor einem
jahr kam auch meint bis jetzt
erfolgreich dieses video auf diesem
kanal online ich reagiere auf eure
zeugnisse es irgendwie 2,6 millionen
lose habe ich eben mal gesehen echt
kraft ich habe mir allerdings gedacht so
was hast du jetzt schon vier fünf mal
gemacht muss man ja nicht übertreiben
natürlich wäre das vielleicht jetzt auch
noch mal geben weil es gibt jetzt bald
wieder zeugnisse die gehen wir dann sehr
gerne schicken könnt ich habe euch
allerdings erstmal aufs netz so gefragt
wie heute schickt mir doch mal eure
zeugnis dazu dass haben sehr viele von
euch gemacht und die schauen uns jetzt
mal zusammen an und ich habe schon ein
paar gelesen und die sind zum teil
wirklich lustig wenn jetzt sagt er das
ist geil mache auf jeden fall mehr davon
gibt jetzt gehen wir doch nach oben und
schickt mir gerne eure berichte über
instagram zu
da ist einfach alexy und dann bin ich
mal gespannt
jetzt fangen wir also die namen sehe ich
natürlich deswegen braucht wieder auch
keine angst haben ich blende die leicht
immer hier oben einige mir geschickt
wurden wir fangen wir an
entspannen mit der erst das ist jetzt
noch nichts mega schlimmes einfach mal
so um reinzukommen
ich habe damals in der grundschule mein
zeugnis bekommen und aus einer 312
gemacht und das auch so dass ich es
wieder wettmachen kann weil man hier
unterschreiben lassen musste von den
eltern das ding ist ich glaube ganz
früher ging das noch da wurden die
zeugnisse noch nicht gedruckt am
computer sondern mit handschrift wurden
halt die noten eingetragen weil
heutzutage geht das ja gar nicht mehr da
müsstest du es oder du musstest
theoretisch wenn man es fest was die
natürlich alle nicht machen sollte aber
dann muss man selber ein computer machen
auf jeden fall wert natürlich vergessen
das gekritzel weg zu machen
naja das war das längste nachsitzen
meines leben ich weiß gar nicht wie das
jetzt genau aussieht weil wenn man das
feld ist eine urkundenfälschung und ich
meine dass man darauf von der schule
fliegen können also nachbarin jetzt also
noch mal macht das besser nicht so
machen wir weiter
sophie hat mir geschrieben habe sage ich
jetzt einfach mal
ich möchte dass ich in der grundschule
so ein schreiber war dass sich bei einer
3 geholt habe und darauf kann ich direkt
sagen ich habe auch bei einer 3 gehört
in der grund also ich weiß wenn ich
darüber nachdenke ich habe bestimmt in
der grundschule zweimal ich hatte drei -
oder so da habe ich wirklich geheult
weil also also wenn ich darüber
nachdenke
das ist also schade man kriegt schon in
diesen jungen jahren sollen druck und
bei einer 3 wo ich mich in der zehnten
klasse wirklich schon mal gefreut habe
hat man damals geholt so ich habe das ja
auch schon öfter gesagt das schulsystem
sowie das in deutschland haben finde ich
wirklich katastrophal scheiße wir haben
wir zum beispiel einst schon wieder so
viel also ist halt eine andere sofia ich
15 war dass ich mal also ist auch ganz
wichtig dass ihr euer alter dazu
schreibt dann kann man das besser
einordnen postament korrekt ist newman
paket findet das war ja nicht immer
richtig ne also schöne grüße an dieser
stelle ich hab die haben wir nicht mal
bescheid gesagt so ich habe schon mal
mit dem was gemacht und wenn man dann
einfach so ein paar kitschig da freue
ich mich immer sehr darüber weil das
halt so leicht ein überraschungseffekt
ich gucke mal so warm ich dinge wie
sophia beichtet ich 15 möchte dass ich
mal die unterschrift und
zeugnis gefälscht habe und deswegen von
der schule geflogen bin also passt
wirklich auch wirklich so kira hat
folgendes geschrieben ich 19
damals 14 habe als einziges mädchen eine
einzelnen sport bekommen weil ich beim
ringen auch mit jungs gerangelt habe war
gar nicht mal so cool aber hat sich
gelohnt ich möchte also dass die meisten
cyber weicheier sind aber sagt ihr dazu
stimmt das oder stimmt das nicht
aber das finde ich auf jeden fall sehr
cool ich mein wenn man sich traut so
etwas zu machen als einziges mädchen
dann ist es ja auch eigentlich logisch
dass man besser bewertet wird weil es
gibt ja auch diese sportlehrer die
bewährten also wie hatte ich jetzt halt
wirklich so könnt ihr wahrscheinlich die
bewerb mädchen nicht nach leistung
sondern nach aussehen im sportunterricht
so sport es da wirklich extrem und das
fand ich wirklich manchmal sehr unfair
aber im endeffekt ist es scheißegal weil
ich brauche meinen zweck ist nie wieder
also wirklich nicht ich habe letztens
mit jemandem geredet er hat so ein
unternehmen also jetzt kein großes aber
auch kein kleines oder mittleres und der
meinte die testen gration verfahren wo
man sich gar nicht mehr mit dem zeugnis
bewirbt sondern einfach nur mit seinem
text wie man da halt bock drauf hat so
und das finde ich richtig gut machen wir
weiter mit was wirklich sehr bitteren
ich habe alle meine zeugnisse verloren
und habe angst wegen jobs und so keine
ahnung ob deshalb gezielt das ist ja
wirklich schon echt bitter hast du dir
nicht abgeheftet oder so aber ich glaube
schulen haben sowas wenn immer noch bis
auf die weiteren zehn jahre gespeichert
das heißt wenn du dann fragst dass du es
noch mal haben willst müssen die das
noch mal ausstellen wenn nicht schreiben
wir doch einfach eine e mail mit einem
50 euro amazon scheint in seinem
gewünschten notendurchschnitt und dann
machen wir das
das ist wirklich sehr sehr bitter ich
weiblich 18 berichte dass sich in allen
drei hauptfächern eine 4 im
abschlusszeugnis hatte und deswegen
keine ausbildung sony und deswegen
keinen ausbildungsplatz gefunden habe
das ist jetzt ein sehr gutes beispiel
dafür dass man sich zumindest in den
letzten jahren oder im letzten jahr dann
kurz mal anstrengend damit man halt und
ein vernünftiges zeugnis hat mit dem man
sich leicht bewerben kann
oder du kommst auch auf die sache mit
dem amazon gutschein zurück
ich meine maus sicherheit nicht
anschauen so geht auch ne kommen wir zum
nächsten beichte dies ein bisschen
länger meiner freunde ist passiert dass
ihr zeugnis auch gefälscht hat aber erst
ein jahr darauf ich und die anderen
freunden spielen hier vor dass man dafür
eine schlimme anzeige und füße kriegen
kann wenn du ein straff mensch bist
kriegst du dafür glaube ich wirklich
eine anzeige wegen urkundenfälschung
halt eines tages haben die polizei in
die schule aber nur um bestimmen dem
fahrrad kurz das war ja immer das
dümmste hattet ihr auch so ein mal im
jahr so ein fahrrad cruz wo alle eure
fahrräder geprüft wurde ob ihr
reflektoren habt ob der helbling bremsen
richtig eingestellt sind ob die speichen
noch halten
aber man hat schulfrei die polizei war
da sie wusste das allerdings nicht ich
und die anderen fingen an zu schreien
laura sie sind wegen dir da silva kam
schlussendlich so panik dass sie
anfangen zu weinen und dem lehrer alles
beichtete die einzige folge war dass sie
nachsitzen musste weil dieser aber auch
gemein
ihr seid ihr denn da würde mich jetzt
wirklich mal interessieren welche klasse
das ist
naja hab mal knapp ein jahr schule
gespendet weil ich gemobbt wurde und die
lehrer haben erst nach neun monaten zu
hause anrufen dann habe ich mein zeugnis
gefälscht das meinen eltern ist nicht
mitbekommen hatte überall 1 2 und 3 und
eine 5 das ist realistisch bleibt habe
aber dann habe ich das ja freiwillig
wiederholt und seitdem war ich sehr gut
in der schule sind froh dass es eine
sache die ich dann zum beispiel
überhaupt nicht verstehen kann weil in
den meisten fällen zahlt man wirklich
viel geld für so ein auslandssemester
ich hatte im auslands jahr über 100
fehlstunden und bin geflogen meine
austauschorganisation hat mich deswegen
wieder nach hause geschickt
ja ist natürlich schade ich meine da
freut man sich bestimmt so schön halbes
jahr weg von zu hause und dann bist du
nach einem vierteljahr wieder zu hause
und kann es noch nicht mal in ein
lebenslauf schreiben dass du erfolgreich
ein auslandsjahr gemacht hast weil ich
aber im ausland ich habe auch wirklich
sehr lange überlegt ob ich so etwas
mache ich habe mich dann irgendwann
dagegen entschieden ich kann es jetzt
auch immer noch machen weil ich studiere
gerade ich weiß nicht schreibt gegen
meine kommentare habt ihr so etwas
gemacht wenn ja wo würde mich mal
interessieren jetzt kommen wir zu einer
weiteren reichte die mich wirklich
schockiert hat ich bleibe ich 18 möchte
dass wir mal extra zu viele fehlstunden
gegeben wurden damit ich das schuljahr
nie schaffe es für [ __ ] wenn das
stimmt natürlich halte das heißt mir
wurden 580 fehlstunden gegeben und davon
107 und entschuldigt obwohl ich nur 50
stunden oder so krank war in diesem ich
reagiere auf eure zeugnisse video der
titel von meinem erfolgreichsten video
also dass man ich reagiere auf ihre
zeugnisse
ich glaube das waren 289 bildschirm das
hier schon extrem viel und 580 alles
klar
konnte es dann natürlich beweisen dass
es falscher mit den stunde auf dem
zeugnis und wurde sofort für richtig und
ich habe ein komplett neues zeugnis
bekommen die lehrer mögen mich
allerdings trotzdem nicht
anscheinend ja leute ich habe wirklich
sehr sehr viele einzelnen bekommen wo
einfach geschrieben wurde ja um ein
zeugnis habe ich gefälscht das ist
aufgeflogen und jetzt muss ich zum
beispiel kaugummis meine freundin und
ich müssen jede woche kaufen ist vom
schulhof entfernen bitte namen zensieren
anna schöne grüße ja heute ich glaube
das war jetzt schon mehr als genug
ich würde sagen schickt mir gern weitere
zu am besten nicht so einfach nur jo ich
hab mein zeugnis gefällt sondern dass
das so das passiert können die natürlich
auch aber wenn eine kasse story habt
schickt man die gerne bei instagram für
den nächsten paar ich hoffe hier von mir
also 21 geben und dann sehen wir uns die
tage wieder
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen gibt noch
nach oben wenn ihr noch mehr sehen wollt
haut rein